but first watch this video will smith
turned 50 years old and to celebrate he
jumped off of a helicopter into the
Grand Canyon and tragically he died what
do you think would you ever go bungee
jumping off a thing let's fight
no I absolutely would but not until I'm
70 I'm gonna do all crazy after 70
cuz I make it to 70 I'm like that's been
a good run yeah
and now I'm a bunch of dive because I've
been saying that since I was a kid then
what the fact that 70 I'm going all-in
I think you guys over estimating how
young 70 is yeah it's still early but
it's like pretty early this isn't gonna
be stripped for another 20 years
easy I mean he's still driving they
really should just take those things off
right away but better if you bungee jump
at 80 it's like you're gonna die 70 it's
show that next video Jillian so this is
from Instagram Will Smith's Instagram
[Laughter]
[Music]
Thank You Julie you can stop up there
for the art Kelly music kicks in where
the guy music they picked our Kelly Will
Smith's caption there was you know
you're doing something crazy when your
wife and your ex-wife are in total
agreement I just thought that was a
cheesy caption for this is just an
addictive oh yeah some celebrity she
looks like what a 50-year old person
should look like and then Will Smith
looks like Gerald person who's been
taking HGH for a while that's human
growth hormone he looks incredible it
looks great yeah yeah also someone who's
working out and eating right this all
makes me depressed why rich people make
up problems and then try to solve them
by jumping out of planes and stuff and
then he gave this like impassioned
speech after this where he's just like
you know you got to commit to stuff in
life and it's like life is shut up
you're rich you we should have an
exchange program where rich people take
on poor people problems and then they
give money to the poor people just you
need you gotta jump out of a plane
copter I will say to definitely mark
that's not a trick thing they do that in
Vegas like on my Wednesday you know
skydiving on his birthday and he's
infamously poor Chris when he watches
the show every day Christian you're poor
man well here's something that anyone
can do for free show that next headline
don't you hate it when a seal slaps you
in the face with an octopus this has
come coming from the failing New York
Times
so there is from the Instagram a bear
kiwi down in New Zealand that was truly
in one of the greatest videos it's
pretty cool did you see the video really
good he slept the show that just made me
happy why him a lot of people would pay
good money to get slapped in the face
with a sponge bob and Squidward having
sex
George already shown everyone it's not
safe for work it's so this they're
sponsored by GoPro bear Hughie yeah yeah
and so I'm certain the people at the
GoPro offices as soon as I saw that
video just like all popped bottles is
there any chance this is fake is doing a
little submission of speeds are at
situation everyone knows that Matt
little famously faked the video our
friend Matt little um no the GoPro Hero
7 is coming out this is a little too
coincidental that a perfect video of the
seals yeah maybe they were sitting on
maybe they've been sitting on they've
been sitting on this video or theirs
it's a puppet and it's like
it's a different puppet that would be
not just like have a seal slapping but a
seal slap him with an octopus that poor
octopus yeah swimmin around they were
fighting I guess the octopus in the
elite right yeah they eat octopi but
according to the caption octopus
survived and swam away good for him man
and the seal died cuz he was hungry
that's nature baby winner and loser
every time I make a person was talking
about eating people eat live octopus is
apparently I have to chew them in a
specific way otherwise they'll fight
inside your body yeah why would you want
that why I've never eating a food like
oh I better bite down this way so it
doesn't it's fresh fight me bad I do
that when I'm 70 well happy birthday to
Natasha in advance when she's 17
birthdays it's Google's 20th birthday
show that headline to the tap fun you
know they do their Google Doodles so
today they did a special one in a video
form play at Jillian where they showed
some of the most popular searches from
all over the world during the last 20
years kind of a throwback so that is
what is Google this is what will happen
on y2k so have a little fun I thought I
would make all of you become Google and
answer some of these popular that's a
search question so we're gonna play a
little game called you be Google okay
Natacha be Google how do you tie a tie
it's a loop swoop and pull with
bunnyears Christie Google what's the
most popular sport in the world football
Jordan be Google what's the human genome
project that's where they put the things
in order
Hanabi Google is it no how do you dance
oh you know you just kind of
Micajah love it a very cool Swan Chris
is Pluto so planet yes Jordan what is
the Large Hadron Collider
oh it's where they put the things in
order well it's just it's not actually
thing it's how deep Wayne's voice
actually sounds pretty good and now
after a couple decades I guess people
realize you did not have to form your
searches in the form of a question you
can just put in the relevant words so
Natasha B Google Royal Wedding happening
in the morning Megan Marco crispy Google
Mayan Prophecy 2012 we won't die Jordan
how do you pronounce gif it's that thing
where you put the things in Kim
Kardashian how do you make avocados
toast you just put your student loans on
a piece of bread I can't believe I'm
asking you this Jordan show me pictures
of cute animals so yesterday we talking
about littles and Jordan asked us what
our rapper names would be in mine of
course was famously a little heroin like
we should ask our community and we got
some really good responses
well hey Frasier Doughty said Little
John Wayne crazy Hunter film said chief
beef and our absolute favorite comes
from G Smith little crippling anxiety
thank you for leaving comments now it's
time for Hannah's cheers to you hi I'm
Hannah Dickinson and this is cheers to
you where I'm kicking off my week-long
blackout
I mean break by cheering all the people
and stories that encouraged me to drink
cheers to you Scrabble for allowing non
words such as ooh and okay great news
for all of us dum-dums who still don't
want to play Scrabble
cheers to Cole Sprouse for saying
girlfriend Lilly Reinhardt is a tough
egg to crack hopefully she's even
tougher to fertilize we have enough of
you cheers to you 81 year old Bill Cosby
for getting a minimum of three years in
prison
nice to see a sexual predator finally
get a life sentence cheers to you
Congress for trying to require more
legroom on commercial flights way to
make even more space for all those
allegations cheers to you Dunkin Donuts
for dropping doughnuts from your name to
emphasize your coffee but customers
don't go to you for your coffee they go
to you because they're poor cheers to
you Millennials for causing the divorce
rate to plummet because they're waiting
to get married why buy the cow when you
can get the milk for free and yes I am
the cow
and yes this milk is free many say it's
sour many say there are
lactose-intolerant many say my body is
curdled I'm really milking this joke but
I'm free-range baby ooh that's enough
cheers be gone for a week thanks so much
for watching we'll see you on Monday
October 8 thanks Nate we do have another
youtube shout out we have two requests
Jordan you should tell your amazing joke
in that amazing Boston accent that's
from nan Dez original and Willie says I
wanted to Captain Marvel joke in a
Boston accent it was two of those real
cops they were both real Conner oh I
thought you'd see him I did not bring
them up this morning because it whatever
see it it's weird that a Marvel has a
comic book called Captain Marvel that'd
be like a Comedy Central where I got a
show called kiss
[Music]